Bulgarian uses the Cyrillic script which  is used by many Slavic languages plus  numerous other languages for most  languages it has some modifications or  variations in Bulgarian it has one  letter which is not used much in other  Slavic languages which represents the  vowel ER it's used frequently in  Bulgarian and we've seen it several  times already in the name of the  language  in the word for house  and in one form of the definite article  suffix  Bulgarian is the only language that uses  this letter as a vowel this letter is  sometimes used in Russian but its  function is to show that the previous  consonant is hard when it would  otherwise be softened or palatalized by  the following vowel check out the full  video on the langfocus channel